Democrats are testing out a new midterm
strategy just call your opponents evil
racist the left taking a page out of
Hillary Clinton's basket of deplorables
Playbook by ramping up their
demonization of the GOP as a new way to
court voters long-time Democratic
strategist James Carville leading the
charge while saying just ignore the Wilk
policies his party pushes
our people are kind of silly their
people actually eat racism is evil all
right misogyny is evil I'm sorry the
problem the Republican party has is they
got really stupid people that vote in
their primaries
and when you have that
you're going to get in really stupid
people demand to have really stupid
leaders and that's where the Republican
party is now
but the smears don't stop there New York
Times columnist Charles blow writing
this op-ed Republicans are America's
problem adding that we must stop
thinking it's hyperbolic to say that the
Republican Party itself is now a threat
to our democracy and former CIA director
Michael Hayden going to a brand new low
after agreeing with a journalist who
tweeted this garbage labeling
Republicans dangerous and nihilistic
Hayden saying quote I agree and I was
the CIA director so uh Joey first I
think we need to ban videos this close
to your face those videos look bad on
everybody
um but is it really that smart for James
Carville to be saying that these voters
are stupid when Democrats are losing
their Coalition especially among
minority voters you know I want to agree
with James Carville that racism and
misogyny uh to its fullest extent are
evil which makes me wonder why James
Carville is coming out of the closet as
a misogynist and a racist after all
these years I mean when you think about
it Jennifer Flowers my not say that
James Carville knows a thing about
misogyny Monica Lewinsky some of the
victims of Bill Clinton who James
Carville worked really hard to get
elected they might think about James
carville's words and say that's not the
GOP you're talking about that's a legacy
Democrats have yeah so Greg we hear a
whole lot about rhetoric and when you
hear what Michael Hayden said as the
former CIA director who hunted people
down with drones all over the world you
wonder what his thoughts are about
people who are here this goes back to I
would say 2015 and now you know why so
many hoaxes and illegalities were
condoned and even encouraged by Intel
experts you can start with Russia
collusion all the way to burying the
laptop if you believe X is worse than
Hitler or X is worse than Isis why
wouldn't you break the rules why
wouldn't you rig the election I said
that after January 6th I said it's like
you know if you've been living in an
atmosphere where people are saying
you're evil and wrong what do you expect
if it so here's the things you you begin
with a journalist who says that um Trump
supporters Republican party worst thing
he's ever seen worse than all these
terrorists if that's true if he actually
believes that why won't you join antifa
why won't you take them out my sense is
that they really don't believe that this
is just hot take rhetoric that that
somehow has possessed them in their
trumped Arrangement hanging out on
social media Zack weismuller of Reason
uh I think it's reason magazine had the
perfect question for Hayden if you
really believe Trump and Trump
supporters are worse than the people you
targeted with lethal drones then what do
you recommend here right I mean you got
to do something worse maybe should
carpet bomb NASCAR but maybe you really
won't do that Hayden because you're a
coward or maybe you really don't believe
it again it's probably just a hot take
and to your original question we've sat
here and we've endured the media and
Intel agents accusing anchors of fox and
Trump of incitement while they do this
Adam kinsinger called All of Us evil
repeatedly said this Cheney was fighting
evil Liz Cheney compared Republicans to
Confederate soldiers Hayden says we're
worse than terrorists you have lost the
right to bring up incitement to anybody
who was angry or upset about being
accused of being called something
finally I have to admit how wrong I was
about the Patriot Act and the Iraq War
all those people from Glenn Greenwald to
mataiibi to Dave Smith to Kat Tiff you
know I dismissed their ominous warnings
that when the government what the
government could do to Muslims they
could do to you and I never believed
that but I'm wrong and so I'm eating
crow well it doesn't tastes delicious
it's a politician saying that yeah in
terms of the midterm elections you know
there's someone who learned a lesson
when they ran for governor at last fall
in Virginia about only focusing on Trump
take a listen
Glenn yonkin has been endorsed by Donald
Trump 10 times
10.
he said so much of the reason why I'm
running is because of Donald Trump Trump
trump we're about to kick off the fall
of the midterm campaign and I tell
Democrats all the time forget Donald
Trump just forget it
so Jessica uh there's been a lot of
focus on Donald Trump especially with
the news what should Democrats be doing
in terms of winning over voters besides
calling them racist misogynists
Democrats have been doing a pretty good
job in the last month or so if you look
at the shift in the generic
Congressional ballot we're now leading
in the average it was supposed to be a
complete shellacking people predicting
up to 60 seats lost we're in the lead
Mitch McConnell was caught in a hallway
this morning asked what he thought was
going to happen with the Senate and he
said we're probably not going to win the
Senate much more likely that we flipped
the house the reason that's happening is
because of Donald Trump's candidates
people like Herschel Walker like J.D
Vance in Ohio Who's down about five
percentage points to Tim Ryan this is a
state that beloved Republicans it wasn't
even purple anymore it was shifting into
the reddest Hue of purple that there is
and so I get it the James Carville is 77
years old he talks like he's 77 years
old he is a brilliant strategist who
delivered a lot of amazing things for
people on left right and Center everyone
loved the Clinton years besides Jennifer
flowers and Monica Lewinsky I'm not
saying that and I've been very clear
about what Bill Clinton did there but
Americans are hearing Democrats loud and
clear about policies that we're getting
past they like what they're hearing and
this rhetoric thing
it's unfair I just spent since the Dobbs
decision came down I have been called a
baby killer more times you know than I
can describe and saying that people are
dangerous for instance I mean
Republicans prominent Republicans call a
socialists call us Communists they say
that the country will turn to Venezuela
if we're in charge what kind of friendly
rhetoric is that right
it's not the former CIA director
on this look digging Terry McAuliffe was
down or was up by 10 points on Glenn
young at this very same time a year ago
and ended up losing so I think it's
probably too early to say that Senate
Republicans are down and out right and
apparently Joe Biden's not the only
Democrat with short-term memory loss
because James Carval and all of these
Democrats ran in Virginia on racial
demagoguery period I have some quotes I
would like to share it not all here's
how badly it failed in Virginia
Virginians and I home state got Glenn
yunkin as the governor and then went
Winsome Sears as the lieutenant governor
the first black woman to ever hold High
office in Virginia and Jason mirrors the
first Latino attorney general while
Glenn Younkin and all his supporters got
called White supremacists that Jonathan
Capehart said this about Glenn yonkin
yonkin won it because Republicans
decided that tap dancing with white
supremacy is their way back into power
of course we got The Little Gym from Joy
Reed which I will Skip and Terry
McCallum said in his closing weekend of
that campaign Glenn Younkin ran a racist
campaign from start to finish Democrats
got shellacked and you know who was
helping out the Crypt Keeper himself he
sent out an email yet wisdom from the
Crypt that could be James carville's
podcast he sent out an email a
fundraising email in late October last
year folks I got to tell you the truth I
hate guys like Glenn young he's courting
right-wing extremist and it did not work
this is desperation dumpster diving by
the by the Democrats this is what this
is it's over right you can smell it do
you remember they they couldn't find a
racist so uh Lincoln project had to
dress him up and bring him in and
pretend to be racist I wonder what
happened to all those activists that
pretended to be Nazis right where are
they they're probably actors there's a
lot of Law and Order being filmed in New
York City they probably at least got
some work but the point is is to paint
all conservatives as kind of the
dehumanize them again because you get
just this Insidious amorphous blob of
people so bigots are upset oh bigots are
up to you can't be upset about crime
bigots can't be upset about putting food
on the table biggest can't be upset
about the family member who died from
fentanyl that came across the border
well what's the original the original
word was evil and I will agree with
Jessica that being called a socialist
and a communist is on par with being
called evil
all right everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now